on change de sujet direction trappe à
présent jusqu'à la fin de la semaine des
travaux de nuit ce déroule à la gare
avec des interruptions de courant une
opération délicate reportages sur des
images des lots ni moins et puis juste
après nous allons nous retrouver sur le
plateau du 7-8 on va parler santé on va
parler don d'organes et prévention
également prévention avec la cpam et
puis justement puisqu'on parlait du don
d'organes on va regarder ce sujet dès à
présent aux journées du don d'organes et
de la greffe une journée mise en place
depuis 2005 par l' oms pour alerter sur
les besoins actuels dans la seule union
européenne 61 mille malades attendent un
don d'organes et chaque jour douze
d'entre eux décèdent faute de
transplantation nous avions suivi l'an
dernier deux frères jean claude chambry
a reçu le rein de son frère alfred je
vous propose de revoir ce reportage de
johanna soudry et de patrick jacques de
dixmude
dès le lendemain de l'opération nous
retrouvons alfred et son frère jean
claude
bien
mieux mieux mieux j'irai mieux qu'hier
parce que hier j'étais en super g on va
pas là après cette intervention qui a
duré quand même plus de trois heures le
prélèvement dure peu près deux heures
deux heures et demie
la greffe dure également une heure et
demie deux heures on était à deux
équipes dans deux salles d'opération
côte à côte dans une salle il ya le
docteur et l'art qui a prélevé par
coelioscopie saviez petit trou une
caméra le rein de monsieur chambry
alfred quand il était prêt à redonner
leur un émoi prêt à le recevoir il a
arrêté la circulation dans le rang de
monsieur alfred chez mme reem la sortie
du ventre on a rincé le rhin bien
refroidi vérifier qu'ils n'avaient pas
de problème on est allé le greffer
pour le donneur aucun traitement
médicamenteux
le receveur lui devra prendre des immuno
suppresseurs qui limiteront les risques
de rejet grâce à l'excellente
compatibilité des deux frères le
traitement de jean-claude serait très
léger alors s'il s'agissait de personnes
plus éloignées sur plan génétique à ce
moment là il peut y avoir un traitement
immuno suppresseurs un petit peu plus
délicat à manier difficile plomb et
c'est qui qui qui nécessite beaucoup
plus d'hospitalisations 800 rhin il est
parti pour marcher 30 ans en moyenne
je suis reconnaissant d'avoir faire un
don un don de son corps pour me
permettre d'avoir une vie normale
et je je je lai pour un frère
l'ombre aspres efforts
des semaines plus tard nous revoyons
alfred le donneur il se remet
progressivement de l'opération quant à
jean-claude le receveur il a pu rentrer
chez lui avec un rein en pleine forme on
a fait un petit repas entre frères hier
c'était génial non non c'est bien
d'avoir mieux maintenant on lui en
vouloir on voit très bien que qu'il a
changé
c'est bien là ce que j'ai fait il n'y a
pas de regret je pense pas je pense pas
ni pour lui ni pour moi
voilà pour ce reportage fort de deux
frères que témoignages que nous avons
recueillis l'an dernier sur tv fil 78